there's a learning process in becoming a
good researcher I became a good
researcher when I was still a computer
scientist and that was something I was
able to take into the biology field when
I chose to become a gerontologist now a
lot of the research process is
understanding yourself understanding
your own mind because sometimes you can
know too much to be able to have a good
idea you can be encumbered by
conventional wisdom and you need to know
when to step back and pace up and down
talk to yourself for half an hour when
you might ought to go to a particular
conference just to get a bunch of new
knowledge when you ought to read a bit
things like that do you just get it in
innate feel for that it's not something
that can really be articulated and toss
however in switching from one field to
another it's important to emphasize that
this has a very long and distinguished
track record of success in research
people who switched making big
contributions more or less at once
because they are unencumbered by
conventional wisdom they have been
trained in a different field so they
know how to do research research is a
very transferable skill but you come in
you know only enough and not too much
and you can come up with new ways of
looking at things
hey